olivier de kersauson
olivier de kersauson bonne forme sommes
très heureux d'accueillir ce soir le
marin le plus célèbre du monde après le
capitaine du costa concordia bien
[Musique]
à
et oui pour être avec nous ce soir vous
avez quitté la polynésie
ouais merci c'est vrai que c'est sympa
la polynésie away génial le problème
c'est qu'il faut supporter antoine qui
crie atol les opticiens
alors olivier vous avait 69 ans vous
êtes l'un des anciens pensionnaires des
grosses têtes de philippe bouvard fait
aujourd'hui partie de la bande à ruquier
mais j'ai découvert que vous aviez une
passion méconnu vous feriez du bateau
c'est vrai sur connerie c'est vrai vous
avez jamais été tenté de quitter votre
boulot d'humoristes de tout laisser
tomber pour faire ch pas moins le tour
du monde à la voile
j'ai été tenté ouais j'ai succombé avec
délice alors avant de parler de votre
nouveau livre a parlé de votre nouvelle
femme est très jolie joue à beauvau
bajaur après une moche
[Applaudissements]
et olivier 60 le vent année érotique
j'aime bien alors vous avez eu un coup
de coeur un peu trash en général on dit
plutôt arrêt cardiaque mais
d'ailleurs la nature m'a doté d'une
constitution qui permet que le coeur
marche encore
ça y est vous avez une alliance non non
je peux pas avoir de trucs sur les mains
ah ouais merde ça faut pas avoir de
trucs qui puisse accrocher ses dangers
moi aussi je vais me marier mais c'est
une bonne nouvelle
bien alors fini les courses autour du
monde parce que j'avais vu la cendre à
moi je ne serai pas tout seul en
polynésie
alors comme disait gainsbourg en parlant
de bambou c'est pas la première mais ce
sera sûrement la dernière non brees a
priori moins marit moi aussi moi je me
fasse virer dans des délais raisonnables
alors on passe au livre maintenant trois
ans après aux chaînes sont qui a été un
best seller vous publié au cherche midi
le monde comme il me parle trois ans
c'est le temps qu'il vous faut pour
claquer vos droits d'auteur ouais c'est
à peu près ça n'en finissait je voulais
faire un un livre dense de réflexion sur
l'amour la mort la coiffure mais j'étais
fait
alors vous revenez sur votre vie vos
courses vos records mais surtout sur
votre parcours intérieur votre
cartographie intime et on apprend des
choses par exemple votre désir de deux
solitudes qui remonte à très loin et un
jour ou visitez dachau et là vous vous
dites si le groupe est capable de ça
alors il faut se méfier du groupe ah
ouais moi j'aimerais mais la sensation
physique ouais je trouve que et notre
société elle fabrique des groupes et si
le groupe n'est pas n'est pas piloté
avec des désirs et des pensées qui
dépasse le mot et veut nommer cuba mois
le groupe va dans le mur c'est que le
groupe ne peut faire que des choses
négatives ou pas très intéressante et
que moi j'estimais que le long seule
capitale c'était mon temps de vie et
montant de vie devait se passer à autre
chose c'est pour ça que j'ai jamais
adhéré à aucun parti
sauf les grosses têtes mais ces
partis c'était le dup
c'était à y aller traire madame rtl
c'était bien
on va vous aimeriez bien être seul à
vaux-le-vicomte c'est un endroit qui
vous plaît particulièrement tout ça très
joli versa et c'est trop grand pour le
vicomte c'est la beauce funk highway
voilà il faut un peu de personnel avec
des patins à roulettes mais ça se trouve
ou alors soit vaux-le-vicomte soit vous
acceptez effectivement de vivre avec
sandra un amour et a une fille qui à 30
ans - que vous savez toutes les émotions
du cap horn non
o'keefe est en train de faire bacha les
conseils du coeur arrête
j'ai trouvé une femme qui veut bien moi
ouais j'ai vraiment content de marquer
ça se passe
alors on va continuer ce voyage intime
avec une interview kersauson par
kersauson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous ne supportez pas si
olivier de kersauson son absence
qu'est-ce que olivier de kersauson a
fait de pire dans la vie
venir ici
quelle erreur olivier de kersauson a
trop souvent commises
erreur de calcul
qu'est ce qui hélas sont chez olivier de
kersauson sa présence dans la durée font
prendre un petit d'audrey enfin nous on
se lasse pas avec qui elle y vient de
kersauson at il été injuste
à peu près tout le monde jusqu'à l'âge
de 30 ans ouais beaucoup moins de gens à
partir de 40
60 5 est avec moi depuis 65
qu'est ce que les vielles de kersauson
devrait arrêter
de fumer en cachette assez bien qu'est
ce qui n'est pas très joli joli chez
olivier de kersauson le dos
créé le défaut majeur de olivier de
kersauson
la différence quand avez vous eu envie
de frapper olivier de kersauson pour la
dernière fois jamais j'aurais trop peur
de la riposte
quelques attaques
pièce qu'olivier de kersauson devrait
apprendre à
être gentil
qu'est ce qui est vrai dans ce qu'on
reproche à olivier de kersauson à mon
avis rien
dernière question qu'est-ce que les
vielles de kersauson essaie de cacher ce
que cache tout être humain qui réfléchit
c'est à dire 7 cette notion profonde qui
nous habite de notre propre impuissance
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linda hardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu